some breaking news to bring you now out  of the united states of america and  court papers related to the search of  former president donald trump's florida  home show the fbi recovered several  documents labeled top secret  u.s attorney general merrick b garland  asked for the search warrant to be  unsealed due to the substantial public  interest in the search  and as he goes on to say the department  of justice's investigation involves  alleged violations of the espionage act  so just to reiterate that breaking news  for you that court papers related to the  search of former president donald  trump's florida home show the fbi  recovered several documents labelled top  secret we'll of course update you on  that story should further information  come into us